[Applaudissements]
on est en direct les chéris je vais
revenir tout de suite sur le dossier
comme ça ce sera fait Valérie et Alex on
est en direct donc on voit bien les
réactions il y a énormément de réactions
sur la danse de Valérie et d'aller je
t'avais dit
tu es devenu fou à mon avis
est-ce que ça va ma chérie oui ça va
en fait je vois en fait
et là je vois que c'est vrai qu'il y a
beaucoup de capture d'écran et je pense
également à toi à patoche
as-tu avoir un petit sursaut non mais
voilà mais je qu'est-ce que je vais
qu'est-ce que tu veux que je dise tu
étais surprise moi aussi voilà
je m'excuse
voilà c'était dans en direct il a il a
il a voulu faire de l'humour et rigoler
etc voilà c'est ça ça a été un peu loin
mais c'est mais voilà tout est aux
États-Unis ça se passe pas comme ça
j'espère non mais on sait qu'il y a
aucune tension sexuelle entre entre
moi j'ai juste appris que Valérie il y
avait une tension sexuelle voilà moi je
me permettrai jamais t'inquiète pas
juste retiens aussi qui ne se passera
jamais rien avec nous à part le mariage
direct Benaim je veux que j'aille voir
tu veux que j'aille voir tes parents
bien sûr tu me le dis Patrick Sébastien
est avec nous la nostalgie on va parler
du spectacle dans un instant aussi avec
Patrick je voudrais juste qu'on vienne
sur les sur cette affaire sur ce coup de
gueule viral d'un chef cuisinier après
un mauvais commentaire sur Internet
c'est tu vois ça Patrick c'est
extraordinaire c'est très réseau voilà
mais c'est le mec est extraordinaire il
est drôle il va être avec nous dans un
instant Olivier Vierzon cette vidéo elle
est incroyable elle a fait des millions
de vues en quelques heures vous allez
voir elles sont de plus en plus nombreux
en avoir marre et à réagir de cette
manière
je te dis à
bientôt c'est pas terrible ce que tu
fais mais en plus le montre à tout le
monde ça a l'air bon
[Musique]
merci Olivier Vierzon d'être avec nous
chef cuisinier au restaurant Hôtel-Dieu
merci d'être là comment vous avez eu
l'idée de faire la vidéo
Oliviera
c'est quand j'ai la réponse de
Tripadvisor micro 20 on entend pas
Olivier merci merci c'est pas ça arrive
de partout hein
tu vas pouvoir gueuler avec ça
bon je disais oui ça m'est arrivé quand
j'ai eu la réponse vraiment de
Tripadvisor si vous voulez quand quand
je m'étais paix auprès d'eux en disant
qu'il y avait une illuminée si vous
voulez qui me balancé un avis qui était
complètement hors sujet et j'avais je
m'en souviens j'avais fait ça à 23
heures et à 23h45 j'ai eu une réponse de
TripAdvisor qui m'a bien précisé
qu'après une enquête minutieuse donc
bien poussé
la vie resterait sur place d'accord ça
veut dire que tu te tais tu la fermes la
virée sur place donc à chaud j'ai rien
dit j'ai attendu deux jours et après
j'ai fait une petite vidéo mais sans
prévenir personne comme ça de mon bureau
et ça a donné ça a donné ce c'est ça
c'était là c'est quoi le commentaire que
Gilles le commentaire en gros c'est j'ai
vu que les desserts étaient décongelés
parce que j'ai vu que il est sortait
juste des cuisines mais cette dame n'a
pas de chance parce qu'elle a confondu
le monde plat avec la cuisine qui ne
sont pas au même étage voilà donc du
coup monsieur a juste titre a réagi là
dessus c'est ça tout à fait il faut le
faire quand même faut le faire après il
y a c'est vrai qu'il y a d'autres avis
négatifs autour du restaurant qui donne
alors moi j'ai regardé la carte il y a
c'est très bien noté mais il y a très
bien noté c'est très bien noté ça donne
envie très franchement j'ai regardé le
menu mais c'est vrai Olivier qui a
d'autres personnes qui parfois émettent
des avis négatifs
service très aimable voilà très bien
cadre joli cours intérieur bon mais très
long ah non ça c'était sur moi par
exemple
[Rires]
cet avis voilà qui est tombé oui et
quelques autres c'est vrai
par exemple piège à touristes adresse
des ventes cours des miracles donc moi
attention je critique pas du tout mais
Olivier quand même quand on est
restaurateur des clients peuvent aussi
émettre des avis négatifs
et malhonnête
faut pas oublier qu'il y a souvent la
concurrence qui fait passer des heures
bien sûr
en l'occurrence en plus c'est pas un
avis négatif c'est que c'est
objectivement faux et le problème de ces
sites c'est qu'il donne un pouvoir de
nuisance à n'importe qui qui va mettre
un mauvais commentaire et vous j'imagine
ça peut vous impacter dans votre
business
fortement si vous voulez parce
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement et on va
dire moi je pense qu'à 80% des gens qui
auraient des avis tu veux que je te dise
j'ai les chiffres Olivier 9 Français sur
10 regarderez les avis pour choisir leur
restaurant moi j'ai dit 80 donc 90% et
c'est pas normal que le site retire pas
le commentaire si c'est faux et c'est
avéré que c'est faux c'est pas normal
que TripAdvisor vous rapporte beaucoup
de monde mais on sait les gars arrêtés
il y a plein de magouilles tu crois quoi
bien sûr il va appeler tous tes potes tu
vas leur faut arrêter de nous prendre
pour des cons franchement et puis il y a
les concurrents c'est que en 2022 1,3
millions d'avis ont été identifiés comme
frauduleux clairement qui était faite
pour nuire et qui n'était pas du tout
des clients mes cours effectivement
voilà ça représente quand même
si vous voulez que les il y a des fois
des endroits où le gars il va il y a je
passais il y a des villes où on va dire
le numéro 1 de cette villa c'est le
kebab du coin j'ai rien contre attention
c'est tout le monde entier kebab j'adore
mais ça veut dire que le gars si vous
voulez si vous voyez il voit des petits
jeunes il va leur dire écoutez les gars
je vous filer une barquette de frites je
vous file 3 canettes et ben c'est moi
des avis et là il prend des avis nous
pour avoir un avis positif à la limite
il faut presque se prostituer s'il vous
plaît ça vous a plu bon écoutez laisse
nous faire plaisir ne faites pas ça
c'est un combat de longue haleine si
vous voulez et si vous voulez nous qu'on
a un mauvais avis quand on a un mauvais
une étoile ne serait-ce que quelqu'un
qui ont dit c'est complet d'accord le
gars c'est complet il prend mal il faut
un mauvais avis et une étoile nous
derrière faut qu'on est au moins 7 8 9
10 avis positifs 5 étoiles pour
récupérer la route là aussi vous
comprenez c'est injuste franchement
c'est injuste surtout que la nature
humaine fait qu'on est plus tenté de
prendre la plume pour critiquer que pour
dire que c'était bon donc en fait ceux
qui prennent la plume c'est souvent les
gens qui qui râlent comme pour les SNCF
les gens qui font les commentaires
exactement
on écrit rarement pour dire le train
valeur à la limite de la délation
presque
cinq fois un message donc je comprends
pas pourquoi sur tous les réseaux
sociaux on devrait pas juste arrêter
l'anonymat et tu as un compte pour une
carte d'identité après tout ils le font
sur les comptes de jeu reste quand tu
veux jouer au poker au machin tu donnes
ta carte et ça devrait être pareil comme
ça ça évite les bottes la folie
déjà pour prouver parce que là aussi
c'est historique parce que parfois
Olivier tu regrettes pas d'avoir fait ça
bah écoutez je regrette pour une chose
moi je suis pas quelqu'un de méchant je
regrette pour Francine parce que
Francine elle prend cher la pauvre et
les francines de France je pense que les
générations futures les enfants ils
éviteront de se faire appeler
franciseur qui m'a laissé un texto tout
à l'heure en disant en chef apparemment
il y a un monsieur qui a téléphoné au
restaurant et qui a dénoncé cette
Francine là ah ouais mais je vais
vérifier avant de me filer son époque je
vais quand même vérifier mais mais bon
la levure c'est pas on cherche pas on
cherche pas non plus le Buzzle moi on
était surpris vous savez ce que au début
si vous voulez qu'on connais mais quand
on a fait cette cette vidéo là si vous
voulez c'est on était quoi à 10000 vues
à 10000 vu je me suis dit oh les gars on
la police dans les mers on était content
autour de la terrasse autour de la table
chef après le monter à 100000 200000
300000 400000 on va commencer un petit
peu faire la gueule on est parti où là
600000 on a c’était pas dit général et à
800000 on a assumé et après c'est
justement c'est Marie Dominique privée
de
France Bleu Périgord si vous voulez
qu'il nous a contacté et depuis on a
fait tu as vu chez elle si vous voulez
et là elle a senti le finance si vous
voulez puis là c'est parti c'est parti
moi je suis un petit peu dépassé tout ça
c'est pas mon métier de venir ici
j'aurais jamais cru retrouve devant chez
vous hein alors vous êtes d'ailleurs
vous avez pas devant chez moi vous êtes
là
mais voilà et merci en tout cas moi
Olivier je vais te dire un truc j'adore
les personnages comme ça voilà tu veux
que je te dise et c'est pour ça que
j'aime la France c'est pour ça que
j'aime les Français c'est des
personnages comme ça qu'on aime et je te
jure moi montre la malveillance moi je
te dis et moi je voilà moi je te dis tu
es incroyable et continue voilà et
j'aimerais manger chez toi merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup merci